Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the,
what do you got there?
I was trying to scare you by putting this dry eye isn't having this Smoko
what happened?
It didn't work.
Ah,
they had just tried to put dry ice in the room.
What's going on is bill Barnes time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Oh,
just checking in on you and
Christmas.
What's going on?
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas to you and to every one,
you know,
um,
I am in a fucking great damn move.
I'll tell you why because all my rose bowl tickets showed up and it was funny,
I was laying them out.
I do it every year for all the fellas.
I take a picture of them when they're all there and I just send them the
picture.
And as I was laying it out,
we got to eight people go in this year.
I was laying them out and just subconsciously,
I don't know if it's because of all the promotion,
I was laying them out and I was just going,
Bah,
Bah Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
And he starts laughing,
going to,
is this your star wars?
And I was like,
you know what it is.
I think it is
woo.
Um,
another rose bowl is coming around.
It's coming around.
Hey,
you know,
I might even go see star wars.
I've been such a cunt about it.
Everybody tells me it's a good movie.
Granted,
I think it's,
you know,
compared to the others,
you know what I mean?
Like you ever see an actor who just sucks his whole career and then he finally
gets a decent thing,
a decent fucking part,
and he's actually above average.
He always gets nominated for an award.
That's the,
uh,
the Holy Shit.
Um,
for one,
she didn't suck Oscar nomination.
You know,
I'm not going to name names,
but you know what happens,
you know what I mean?
That whole fucking career there.
I don't know what they're doing.
Dead deer fucking,
uh,
they're always play this way.
They're always playing a cowboy.
You know,
the whole fucking time.
They're always playing a cow
boy.
Yeah,
I'll get those engines out of here.
What power?
White power.
Right?
Doing all the car.
They always lived the white power part up.
But you know,
howdy ma'am.
They do all that shit and they want a gun fight and that's all you see him
fucking do it.
And then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
they play a postman who they're like,
oh my God,
he was so believable.
I mean,
the hotel by just,
I thought I could never see him as a cowboy.
And then there he wants
the little chain that led to his keys that opened stuff up for the mail.
I,
I mean,
I bought it.
I was in,
he's really good,
you know,
or the in shape.
Good looking guy gains a little bit of weight,
you know,
or the hot chick does it wear any makeup.
And they go,
it's so brave.
So brave.
We have to give her something shiny.
Um,
so anyways,
people are telling me as good,
so I got to get all this shit out about that entire fucking thing.
I don't even know why I care.
I don't think I care.
I think I just like being a cunt.
I think I like when I see a group of human beings excited,
I like to throw a little rain on it,
you know,
I don't know what that says about me.
Probably says it deep down inside.
Maybe I'm not the happiest person.
And when I see joy and others,
it reminds me of my own sadness
or those movies are a little overrated.
Uh,
Geez.
Belt.
Can you let it go?
Sorry.
I'm also,
I'm very excited because,
um,
after it's for family,
uh,
I've got nothing but a wonderful,
um,
tweets from everybody.
It's stuff on Facebook.
It's been,
everything's been positive except two people.
One guy was just like,
oh,
okay,
kid paternally to is going to be as funny as you stand up back.
So whatever.
Um,
which was kind of a compliment as he,
uh,
you know,
took the nonexistent DVD of my new series and it's just slap me in the face with
it.
So it was weird.
It was,
it was an abusive relationship.
So obviously I'm attracted to him now.
Um,
I'm sorry.
And then what else did I get?
I got another one.
Um,
oh fuck.
It was funny as hell too,
and the guy was legitimately
not enjoying the series.
Ah,
fuck.
I can't remember.
It's still my favorite one of all was when we just showed the pictures of the
characters with a little bit of music and no dialogue.
And that guy wrote and the shark has been jumped.
That's all he needed to see.
Oh,
I needed to say.
It was just pictures of the characters.
He didn't need any dialogue.
He didn't need the story.
All he needed was those pictures.
A little song.
And 23 years of me being in this business,
we're just flushed down the toilet.
I hope the person who sent me that tweet is listening to this because I want you
to know,
we,
uh,
got together all the writers to,
to uh,
get ourselves a little headstart if we get a second season.
And I mentioned that to all the writers and we were all dying laughing.
We thought it was,
it was,
you know,
obviously you don't like getting shit on,
but some of them are so ridiculous that it's funny.
So now that's become a running a running joke in the writer's room now,
and the shark has been chomped.
So anyways,
um,
but of course a Netflix doesn't give out rating.
So technically I don't know how it's performing,
but I do,
you know what I mean?
If it sucked,
I would have been getting a bunch of,
uh,
Jesus.
Oh,
Hey,
at least you're standups.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
And with that,
let's talk a bull games.
Six 58 fucking bowl games today.
Uh,
I don't think I'm going to watch any of them because yours truly has been
crashed
at the gym.
I go to the gym every day.
It's just become pop me life.
Right?
And you don't want a bay while you go to the gym every day.
You can't.
Right.
So,
um,
I just been going,
what's the matter?
Ain't get the cake.
Yeah,
we're on good terms again,
right?
Yeah.
You're like me and Nia had the classic male female argument that no matter how
much time do you give them,
they're never ready.
You're never ready.
Hey Nia,
listen,
what goes to a party Thursday,
uh,
June 26th,
2017 can you be ready by four ouncer I just,
I just don't get it.
I sit there and I was driving back from where I was coming from.
Right.
Jeremy was some friends,
man.
So I called you and I said,
Hey,
I'm 15 minutes away.
And you're like,
oh,
still trying to decide what I want to wear.
And I said,
okay.
The hung up and do you know why I was yelling at the windshield?
Because he knew I wasn't going to be ready.
I was just like,
hi,
you're not ready.
How is she not ready?
She had three and a half hours,
three hours and 20 minutes to get ready and you were not ready.
I thought that you were going to come in and change clothes.
I'm a guy.
I'm always ready.
I can,
I can literally get ready at eight minutes.
But you're right.
I did watch that last episode of making a murderer.
I knew you did.
I can get ready to eight minutes and back in the day it was 15 yes.
Sit down.
I want you to come here.
Let's say that again into the microphone.
Tell me what happened.
I was watching the last episode of making a murderer.
Um,
don't binge watch that series if you haven't watched it.
It's not good for your soul.
But I had to stop watching it.
Yeah.
And then I want to sign the petition to help that guy up.
Uh,
let's stay on.
Sorry.
Okay.
Yeah.
Forget about the guys wrongfully imprisoned for the second time.
Let's start with what me and my selfish needs.
Yeah.
So I watched the last episode that,
and then I fell asleep on the couch.
Okay.
So that's what happens.
So all the histrionics.
So then we were driving to the party.
We're driving to the party,
she's dressed up,
I'm dressed up,
we're both staring straight ahead now talking to one another.
And as we're pulling up the fucking driveway,
she goes,
oh,
we should have brought a bottle of wine or something.
And then I said,
well,
God knows she had plenty of time to do it.
And you know what the evening is?
Michael Corleone would say was,
oh,
godfather part two.
It was over and for the rest I got to give it to you if the rest of the party
you smiled and you pretended like we were a cohesive couple.
That's true.
Yes you did.
And you acted like he cared for each other though.
No,
he didn't.
I actually went into the kids' room and I watched fast and furious with the kids
and enjoyed it at the same level that they did because I'm immature is health
and I just,
you know,
chatted with other people about making a murderer and soaked in bleach.
Okay.
So then we get home and she still hasn't said anything.
I remember we pulled up in the driveway and then she goes,
you know,
I'm going to get out now.
And it just got out,
walked around the car and went into the house and I'm like,
oh,
she's mad.
And then we go downstairs and you are putting fresh sheets on the bed.
And I said something about his sleeping in the bed today together and just
looked at me and said,
Oh,
I'm sleeping here tonight.
At which point I just tapped it.
The German Irish of wealth.
Fuck you.
I can play the silent game all night and I didn't say another word to you.
Well we talked a little bit.
No,
you tried to initiate it because you realized that no matter how much you hate
me,
you like sleeping next to me in a bed and I do love stuff with that
condescending tone.
No
sleeping next to you.
It's weird.
If I were to sleep in a different place personally,
I was looking forward to it.
I had,
I had the fucking NHL network ready to be queued up the second you walked out
and then you came in and then I literally had to fake asleep like I was eight
years old,
which I did,
which is pretty sad,
right?
Like nudge you because you left your laptop on the bed and I was like,
can you put this on here?
And I was mature enough not to say,
I almost said I thought you weren't sleeping here
and you've been
stop up the stairs extra loud to reinforce I'm leaving now.
At which point I wouldn't have done anything and then you come.
Don't,
don't,
don't back down.
I really can't tell you.
Oh,
maybe some of it though.
Okay,
so you go.
All right.
So in the future,
Nia,
just give yourself an extra four,
five,
seven hours.
No,
I know,
but it's like I never know what to fucking wear and then I had to figure out how
I want to wear my hair based on the outfit.
Do you ever think this is why men are more successful aside from sexism and all
that shit?
It just takes you guys too God damn long to get ready because I like to look
nice and I,
you know,
but it does take me too long to get ready.
It's true.
I'm overthinking it a lot of the time,
so I won't take that.
Tell you,
you shave your head of cuts at least five minutes off the prep time.
Oh well I'll make,
I'll make a note of little [inaudible] thing you gotta do,
you know,
style it up.
What does that noise you made?
I was supposed to be me,
Robin and the Moose in my hands back in the day when he used to style it up.
You know,
all back in the day when you used to put the fraud act in your hair when I was
young.
When you had here.
Yeah.
All right.
Get out of here.
Go get your cake.
I'm going to go pick up the Christmas Day.
All right.
Merry Christmas everybody.
Merry Christmas to you and you are forgiven.
I am forgetting your forget.
Yes for being a jerk face yesterday.
All right,
I'll take them.
Okay.
And deal.
All right.
Get out of here.
There we go.
Um,
tragedy.
Avert it.
Oh,
I stuck with them out.
I stayed in the pocket on that one.
She tried to turn it around about all the shit that I'm doing,
you know?
And I was just like,
Hey,
I know all the shit where doe God knows.
I know all the shit we're doing and I know that I'm doing and I know you know
that shit that I'm doing it.
I'm fucking on it.
You know,
I haven't yelled about sports on speaker phone the whole fucking week.
All right?
I haven't done that once.
And that gave me credibility.
All right,
to never fucking ready.
I don't give a fuck how much time you give them.
They're never fucking right.
Anyone kills me.
Then they get in the car and they're putting their fucking makeup on and then
over the years you got all that makeup on.
The fucking vice
drives me nuts.
They're like,
oh Geez is an eyeliner and lipstick.
Somehow it gets on your fingers and it's like,
it's like sort of going,
it's like an adult five-year-old,
you know?
Do you fucking have a kid?
You know there's going to be cheerios and shit all over your car,
right?
And if you've got to broaden your life,
there's going to be makeup all over the Fed.
They don't give a fuck,
you know,
and you bring it up in your own country way.
What do they do?
They cry.
You know what they,
you know what I'm going to make my million dollars on.
I'm going to make a fucking adult baby seat for a woman.
Right?
So when she's in a bad mood,
like what I do for a family,
just sticker in there.
Right?
And you got a fucking pacifier that's like Chai Latte,
fucking Frappaccino,
whatever the fuck they liked.
Flavor to be all these different flavors.
Pie Adult pacifiers for women and you stick it in there and then you leave.
Right?
I know it was a lot of women listening right now.
Well what about,
what about one for guys and all I say to is that why don't you come up with an
original idea
joining the NFL hoe.
You guys got a lot of nerve.
This is really country for the holidays,
isn't it?
Um,
let's see.
Typing in my password here.
Every fucking God damn day.
Here we go.
Here we go in.
There we go.
Alright,
let's,
what are we going to talk about?
So anyways,
my big thing,
um,
I've been dying to cook something cause the holidays Bodo [inaudible] are here
and I like to have some big tray of something that people could just be eating
on when the hanging around the house.
I got some family coming in.
It's possible that a New Jersey Zone,
the pride of Newark,
the Trenton All star himself,
Paul Versey might be staying here for a couple of days.
So,
uh,
there's this thing I was watching,
I was watching an old molto Mario Mario Batali on,
um,
on youtube and I can't believe I used to watch that shit like 15 fucking years
ago.
Okay.
Where's the fucking time going?
Right.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
I used to watch that,
but at a Dadda Dadda Dadda I used to watch it every fucking day at noon and uh,
I didn't even try 99% of the shit that he was making.
I never even tried it,
but just watching him every day,
I just kind of started to learn stuff.
So he makes this Lazada Nah.
MMM.
That is,
that looks just absolutely fucking insane.
And it's like a spinach type lasagna noodle that he makes,
which I've never tried.
And uh,
I want to make a fucking tray or that like the day before Versie comes out.
All right.
Just so I can make sure if I fuck it up,
I don't get,
I don't serve it to them cause they'll Sicilians,
they never fucking forget.
Right.
So I'm going to,
I'm definitely going to try to bang that out and then he's got this,
uh,
what was this hunter's chicken or some shit that looks fucking incredible.
Um,
I dunno,
I go through these phases where I just like cooking so I'm back into that type
of shit.
So I'm gonna try and do that.
I've been crushing it that to Jim anyways.
I haven't gone there yet today.
Um,
but I didn't know if it's open because it's new year's Eve,
but down near where I played drums,
this is open area where it's got like pull up bars and like jungle gym shit.
But like for adults and like homeless people that hang out around,
you know what I mean?
It's definitely,
if you have your sweatshirt on and you get a little hot,
you leave it on because you know,
if you turn your back it's going to be gone.
Or some homeless guys going to be using it as like a pillow.
Um,
hey,
it's this bad.
I was watching last night when I was ignoring my wife,
being a fucking child myself.
Uh,
and they were interviewing these homeless people who have like no place to go
and all of that type of stuff.
And they were just saying,
you know,
we sit here and we see people shopping for Christmas and you know,
I'm thinking like,
uh,
you know,
I wish I had a family.
I wish I had somewhere to go and it was making me feel bad,
but you know,
I just went to which one time they just interview just the lazy homeless person
who was just like,
yeah,
you know,
I just never liked having a job and a one thing came to another and I ended up
out here and uh,
you know,
kinda sucks in the winter,
but overall it's not bad,
you know,
for as much as I wear the same pants every fucking day,
I can take a nap whenever I want to.
I don't have anybody telling me what to do.
Right.
I'm eating,
drinking,
I'm fucking hanging out.
Just sort of existing and stills gets still gonna suck.
I think it'd be better to be homeless out in the woods.
He sure enjoying nature.
Right?
If I was fucking homeless,
I'd be homeless down here like a ballpark.
Now,
where can he go?
Can you take a shower?
The big thing is you got to take a shower.
It would be awesome is if he knew someplace we could shower in a place where you
could steal new clothes every four to five days and then you could just sort of
walk around it,
just not have a fucking job.
You know,
sleep outside.
You get used to it after a while.
I mean,
when you really think about it as much as they are homeless,
don't they?
Just sorta of cavemen and the modern day and we would fucking slap outside.
Back in the day,
native American slept and teepees.
You had a little bit of shelter.
You can't tell me like a box isn't in the same family tree as far as shelter.
It's lower than a teepee or a fucking cave.
You know,
like when they do the coaches like tree,
like I was telling you where Paul Brown under the,
in his coaching tree was Don Shula,
Bill Walsh,
chuck Noll,
blood grant.
Like say like the cave,
you got the cave and the family tree off of that.
It's got to be the fucking tp,
the Wigwam,
the box,
a refrigerator with no door on it.
Right.
That'd be an interesting series.
The upside of being homeless.
Yeah.
I think it's even better.
I feel like just,
uh,
if you sort of a booze hound,
you know,
I don't mean like just like killing yourself.
I just mean like shit faced.
Like every day you drink,
like you'd go into a game and he just keeps fucking hammered.
Right.
And you just sorta hanging out on the street.
I'm sorry,
appeal.
I'm trying to,
you know,
this podcast started out so negative.
I figured I'd take something negative and maybe put a little sunshine on it.
You know,
like I tell,
you know,
it was crushing it.
People who are homeless in Santa Monica,
you,
you're literally homeless where people vacation,
you know,
or like Marina del Rey.
Just walking around looking for a boat.
Nobody's been on in a minute.
Right?
Curl up on the deck.
Just laying there.
I are meaty.
All right.
Maybe it does suck.
I think it would just get exhausting after a while.
Cause I've,
I've locked myself out of the house,
you know,
a couple of times,
more times than I would like to admit.
And I gotta tell you,
just sitting around outside is a,
it's fucking exhausting.
It's probably why cavemen were never fat.
A lot of people these,
cause they didn't eat as much,
but it was just that exhausting the stress of not having a door that you could
just fucking close and lock and know that nothing was going to come along and
eat you.
I think,
uh,
I think that stress alone.
Did I just invent a new diet?
Hi everybody.
This is bill burr.
I have a new diet for you.
It's called the remove your front door and go to sleep at night diet.
You'll wake up every eight seconds.
So the stress of it,
it's gotta be something in there.
He was throwing yogurt and just say probiotic.
You know,
do you ever wonder why our ancestors were in such great shape is cause they were
in fear for their lives 24,
seven even when they were sleeping,
they,
their,
their metabolism was still going.
Cause at any second they realized that they might have to outrun a Willdabeast.
Right.
If we could just somehow get back to that three days a week if he just removed
your front door and went and fell asleep on the couch closest to the front to
the front door.
You know,
that reminds me,
I remember one time at the shady chick on the road and we fucking hooked up.
And,
uh,
it seemed,
everything was cool at first and then like she started telling her story,
you know,
you start steering the conversation towards sex,
you know what I mean?
Just,
you know,
Shit,
you're doing your 20s,
you don't have any game.
And she started telling me how.
Okay,
we haven't yet gone going back so far you make when you talked to a woman,
right?
And you start talking to them about sex.
Okay.
And they're open to it.
And yet they had that experience where you're like,
oh yeah,
here we go.
It's all set.
It's all set,
it's all set.
And then it just passes that tipping point to be like,
ah,
well,
you know,
I got,
obviously gonna wear,
it's not that bad all the way to the point of like,
holy fuck,
all right.
You know what?
I forget it.
Forget it.
You know,
this was a bad idea.
That's what happened with this.
This person was open and I was discussing things and uh,
I don't know how we went from a,
hey,
I think he kind of cute.
You want to hang out to her telling me that she hosted a sex party.
And I was like,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
what,
what?
What'd you say?
She goes,
I hosted a sex party.
And she said,
I said,
what is a a,
what's a sex party?
She goes,
well,
you know,
you rent out all the rooms on the same hotel floor and then everybody just
leaves their doors open and people just walk around going in and out of each
room and you just fuck whoever is in there.
So at that point I decided that,
all right,
I don't know if I have the level of protection.
I don't know if they make a condom for that.
So,
uh,
what,
what did we did things that there was no way that you could get catch anything
is basically it.
And then I didn't know how to get her out of there,
so we fucking fell asleep.
And I,
this is when I was really introverted and didn't know how to say what the fuck I
was thinking.
I remember she was sleeping on the right side of the bed and it just so happened
my watch,
uh,
was on that side,
nightstand and I was on the other side of the bed and I swear to God,
I woke up like fucking like 58 times at night.
Just kept getting up,
looking,
seeing her there and making sure the watch was there rather than just being
like,
listen,
can,
uh,
can you just get the fuck out?
I wouldn't say if you get the fuck outta here.
Uh,
but you know,
I bet I lost a lot of weight that night.
All right,
you guys ready?
You guys ready for some advertising with this fucking battling before the,
uh,
before Christmas here for the fuck.
Where in hell is it?
There it is.
Oh,
we got one.
He's down to one people.
Only one read.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I feel like a coach.
It's about ready to get fired.
All right.
Zip Recruiter.
A.
As a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Posting jobs in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves little time to post it.
Dozens of job sites and don't we all know that position?
Ziprecruiter is the solution.
Why do they always leave that line in there?
You should do that with your copy.
All right,
here we go.
Now this is me.
Positioning Ziprecruiter is a solution.
Tears is a deal.
You can post to 100 plus job sites,
sites with one single click.
You'll instantly be matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus you can watch brand new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's,
easy to use interface within 24 hours.
It's Ziprecruiter has been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um,
today.
You can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
ziprecruiter.com/birth I don't know why they would see position yourself to
think sells itself via to hire somebody.
I didn't want to go through all the fucking rig tomorrow,
right?
You're like,
how am I cursed and used an old person?
Think I said when the fucking,
and they also said Rick Tomorrow.
Um,
or maybe he didn't like it anyways.
Yeah.
Why wouldn't you use that shit?
Okay.
Pill.
We get it.
All right.
You're,
you're a little on edge.
This is,
this is how I act when I'm happy.
I still have tremendous level of anger.
I don't know what it is.
I'm trying to get rid of it,
you know,
it is.
I am played drums today.
I haven't worked out and I'm bouncing off the fucking walls and you know,
my wife goes,
she,
you know,
we're having people over and she wants me to go get a cake.
Insulin.
I'm saying like,
why don't you just have me fucking make one?
You know?
She's like,
it's just either it's down the fucking street.
She goes,
oh,
can,
can you go get the cake?
Can you go get the fucking cake?
And it's just like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
you mean from the bakery that's in the opposite direction of where I'm going?
And she goes,
oh,
I didn't know that.
I go,
you know where my gym is?
She goes,
hmm.
Where is,
okay wait,
I know.
Where is it again?
It's just like,
well,
you stopped doing that.
I know.
You know where it is.
I just called you out on it and now you're going to try to polish.
It's just,
they think,
you think he's so fucking dumb.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
I'm even getting sick of my voice on this one.
I'm sorry man.
I don't know what happened.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I came here,
I thought that this was going to be like a Christmas special.
Evidently it's not going to be so settling.
Um,
people were sending me a,
uh,
this video of this Pelican eating a pigeon alive of course,
because a Pelican can't hold a pistol or a knife.
So basically what happens is a Pelican just sort of walks up,
turns his head to the side and uh,
puts the bird and it's a big giant double Chin and a,
you know,
just sorta whacks it on the head with it's beak.
Like they don't really have to,
they have teeth.
I don't think they do.
One of the comments that he said they got bit by one said it didn't hurt.
Maybe they were trying to be macho.
And let me see this is,
will this put me on a list?
If I look this up,
two Pelicans have teeth,
uh,
oil.
There's a picture right there.
Let's see.
Images for two.
Pelicans have teeth.
I don't see any,
I don't see any at all.
They definitely got a veiny fucking double chin.
That's the worst man.
As you get old and you get that fucking Pelican Chin,
that's why you got to do the cardio because you fucking skin on your face is
going to fall anyways just because of gravity.
But good Lord.
I'll tell you,
nothing makes me want to do cardio then looking at a fucking pillock.
I need to fucking pigeoned.
Right.
All right.
Let's see here.
There are more than half a dozen species of telecons.
Don't you hate when the Internet just won't answer your fucking question
immediately?
It's like,
I'm dumb.
Can you just help me out here?
I don't need the entire history.
It's like when you buy a history book,
they always like,
okay,
let's read about the history of World War II.
They always got to start 20 years before.
It's like,
I get it,
shit happened,
and then they started fighting.
Can you get to the fucking battles already?
You got to get like 80 pages in before the thing starts.
All right.
There were over half a dozen species of Pelicans,
but all of them have the famous throat pouch.
Oh,
is that what they call a double chin?
I said,
good and sell for somebody.
I don't know buddy.
Yeah.
Really?
I want you to take care of that fucking throat pouch.
It's a Pelican reference,
uh,
for which the birds are best known for these.
I bought the bar,
plastic pouches to catch fish through Yada,
Yadda,
Yadda.
And many,
many Pelicans fish by swimming in cooperative groups stay more form a line or a
u shape.
I don't give a shit.
All right.
How about this?
Okay.
Pelican bite.
A kid bitten by.
Okay.
This is a kid getting bit by a Pelican.
Not this kid cries.
Yeah,
we know that he's got some teeth.
Here we go.
Do you wanna stand near him and I'll take a photo.
Yeah,
but that parent
sounded more like the uncle
no longer is this fucking video.
All right.
It's only 58 seconds.
Oh,
all right.
But the little five ladies,
if the toddler
fucking
yeah,
he's fine.
He gave him a little nip.
You bit him in the shoulder.
In the back.
Yeah.
It would've been so fucking funny to get the kid in there and the kid was
wiggling around like the fuck I dead bird.
Uh,
Jesus Christ and see if there's an alarm on Pelican bites.
Man at the zoo.
Let's see if this guy could take it.
Hi Judge.
You by that guy.
Unless he's a fucking masochist.
Yeah.
They don't have teeth,
you know,
so it's so fucking funny.
I don't even know why I was looking at that up.
Why was I looking it up?
Oh yeah,
so they,
I guess that's why the,
the,
the pigeon was suffering so bad.
He had the fucking swallow that thing whole and then he just sort of bags it on
their head.
You know,
we opens,
it closes its mouth just banging on the fucking head.
I think at that point he's just trying to bust up its wings.
I Dunno.
Okay.
From what I saw was kind of like getting beaten to death by a ruler where it
would be somebody just kept hitting in the head with it.
It would be like annoying,
more so than a devastating,
you know.
Okay.
I guess,
you know,
if,
if you're going to get beaten to death with something when you want it to be
like a machete,
I want against sue somethings,
you know,
one one and done.
It's kind of like if you're going to get eaten by a shark,
you want a great white right and you want to know it's coming and you stick your
face under the water,
see where it's coming,
and then you just swim head first right into it's fucking mouth just ended.
They'll come up and take a chunk out,
a part of my hip and my torso to see if I'm edible and then fucking swim around.
And as I'm sitting there going like,
Oh God,
Oh fuck that head first.
Right into the goddamn think.
That's what I say.
A lot of people say punched the shark and the nose,
so it goes away.
I don't say that.
I say stick your head right and it's fucking mouth.
Um,
all right.
Is that going to be an,
I thought there was a few of the things I wanted to talk about.
Uh Oh,
I mentioned,
I'm still saying with the Mike Johnston Bass drum work on,
I'm going to go try and do that today.
Hopefully if the rehearsal spaces open Pelican,
eating pigeon,
if any other drummers out there to want to listen to something cool.
I just looked up a Stewart Copeland,
uh,
drums only and uh,
you know,
saw,
synchronicity,
Roxanne and all that and all that little cool slick shit he's doing on his high
hat.
Um,
sometimes those patterns he does on the ride cymbal with the bell.
It's fucking really fucking cool.
Um,
so that's it.
Everybody.
Uh,
it's the,
it's Christmas Eve.
Christmas is tomorrow.
In case you didn't know.
I want to wish all you guys and Merry Christmas,
happy Hanukkah,
happy Kwanzaa.
And uh,
you know,
I said this last week.
What do Muslim celebrate this time of year other than the death of infidels?
Alright,
wait,
Muslim.
Well,
they wouldn't have a Christmas.
They don't believe in Jesus.
What do Muslims do on Christmas?
All right,
this is NPR.
So you know,
it's going to be nice and liberal.
If it was Fox News,
I wouldn't have read it.
I'll tell you what they do and they plot that death of Santa Claus.
Uh,
all right.
For many American Jews,
Christmas Day means Chinese food and movies.
But how do American Muslim spend their time at Christmas?
Jesus is also revered as a prophet in Islam.
Islam.
I didn't know that.
Islam,
Muslim,
Muslims.
Um,
I always find people when they're passive,
aggressively racist.
What they do is they deliberately mispronounced like they say,
Muslim instead of Muslim.
Right.
And I just did that with Islam.
I said Islam,
but that's just because I suck at reading.
All right?
Muslims and Christians believe that Jesus is the only messiah.
Okay?
Wait a minute.
There's no way we both agree with dad were fighting like this.
It really is about oil.
I don't know what the fuck.
Okay.
Explains his Sharm Maha mode,
Mou d and Arabic teacher at Harvard University.
He points out that Jesus',
his mother,
Mary,
is considered by Muslims to be a saint.
In fact,
there's an entire chapter in the Qur'an called Mary,
and the story of Jesus's birth is recounted in this chapter.
He says,
okay,
this is why I think that everybody sorta was believing the same shit and we just
swell.
Shut off.
You know,
it's like the Zildjian factory,
you know,
when they made symbols,
it was an Armand Zildjian,
you know,
he had his kids underneath them,
they all were great and then he dies and the two had gotten to a fight in the
next thing you know,
there was diligence and bits,
right?
A Christmas Day,
Maha mode,
and is devout Muslim family fast.
Okay.
Oh God,
that's so fucking smart.
Fucking whale.
After tomorrow,
we also relate the story of Jesus and Mary says,
we read those passages in the Koran and we make sure the holidays focus through
and through Jesus,
peace and blessing be upon him as opposed to feeding into the commercialization
of this holiday.
Jesus Christ.
Is this real or is this guy just nervous?
Cause he's in America on Christmas.
Uh,
that's not to say that some American Muslims never participate in more
commercial side of Christmas.
All the Persians in my community went full blown Christmas the first year says
Comedians,
highroad norb Bosh.
Wow,
that's a fucking sick ass last name.
It ends with k.
H.
S.
I mean,
my cousins even had a guy come over dressed as Santa.
Yeah.
I mean that's like fucking white people celebrating Cinco de Mayo.
You know,
I,
I celebrate it.
And I also say,
what day of the year is it?
5th of May the a douchebag.
Okay.
Then there's the nuts.
Much going on approach.
No one did anything in the home of,
all right.
All right.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And then there's the kind of doing something but not really approach.
All right?
So it gets,
it's a bunch of different ways to do it.
I didn't think the Muslim Muslim people,
uh,
even addressed now,
wait a minute.
Do we address Muhammad?
Okay.
You are,
the problem is,
is religion is so fucking boring as a kid that you just want to get away from it
as an adult.
So now that's Shit's actually interesting to me.
So it's all sort of the same people.
So it's kind of like a religious supergroup.
Right?
We got Lennon,
McCarthy,
Ringo and George Harrison.
You get cheeses,
you get Muhammad,
you got Abraham,
right?
He's a guy led people out of the desert.
Yeah.
And then who's the best?
Who's the food's Ringo?
Buddha.
Okay.
And they all kind of say the same shit,
right?
He was fucked up the other day.
I was on a hike and I went by some desert plant that literally had like a
Stinger on it and I hit my finger on it and it felt like I got stung by a bee
like a minute later.
And now my finger,
uh,
just in that area is black and blue,
but I don't have any tingling or anything like that.
So being that I'm a guy,
I won't read up on it,
nor will I go to the doctor.
So if I die by Monday,
just know it was a,
some sort of a exotic desert plant.
All right,
well,
you know what,
then happy fasting,
um,
ice.
You know,
I used to do that once a week.
I got into fasting for a minute.
I would do it like once a week.
I'll tell you,
that's a great way to stay in shape.
Just not eat one day out of the fucking week,
you know,
provided if you do it the right way,
when you don't eat,
you're not supposed to then just get out and drive a car and go to the gym and
Shit.
You supposed to like fucking chill,
you know,
and a relaxed all day,
which of course I never did cause I'm a maniac.
I actually know somebody that has a friend that uh,
the person eats every other day and I got to tell you,
they're in great fucking shape.
You know what I mean?
Okay,
well I've talked myself into a corner.
Well listen,
I have a merry Christmas parties.
I've already wrapped this up like 10 times.
Enjoy the second half of the podcast where we got some throwback,
a more dumb shit that I've said over the past few years.
Actually the past decade and some music from are the one and only Andrew stem
lists.
All right.
And have yours [inaudible] yourself a merry little Christmas tomorrow.
It is a spring.
Moses,
you are the sunlight.
So
it isn't hard to feel me.
Alright.
Dilemmas for the week.
Go to the bathroom like a cat number one and number two in a dresser drawer size
cat box and have a butler empty at every day or go to the bathroom like a dog
outside in the bushes and have a Butler follow you around to pick it up and tell
you that you're a good boy.
Oh,
that's no fights.
No Fiat that second one.
I do it outside.
Squat right down to the fucking pushes.
I'm not shitting inside my house.
That's why I hate cats.
Aside from the fact that they act like stuck up concert a club,
you know who've never done accomplished anything other than looking good in
life,
you know,
and they only come around when they fucking need something.
The only other reason why I don't like cats and say shit in the fucking house,
then I got to pick it up.
I don't like that.
They're not happy when I come home.
There's just no,
there's no give and take.
You know what it is when you have a cat,
you're basically Robert De Niro's character and casino.
That's what you are,
you know,
and your cat is Sharon Stone.
She's fucking,
she's just there for the amenities.
You fucking cunt go d and a Goddamn red roof inn.
All right.
So yeah,
I would definitely outside who doesn't like being told they were a good boy?
I get praised.
What was the last time anybody out there got praise after they took a dump will
not be awesome,
you know?
I don't know.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Was that unfunny sir?
Did you not like that one?
Was that not up to your comedy standards?
Did you feel the rest of this podcast was funnier than that?
When I blew my nose before I went off on Jesus.
Oh,
alright.
Let's just plow ahead here.
Number two.
Uh,
would you rather marry a stripper or have your daughter become one?
I'd rather Mary would rather marry one.
You know,
if my daughter becomes one,
that's just complete failure as a parrot.
And in fact that's what I think all those videos,
it should be called that you see,
you know when you see on Youtube when you got those girls do,
when those booty dances,
you know the god damn shorts up their ass.
Like,
it's always like someone,
so booty dancing,
what it should be called is.
So it's so complete failure as a pair of results of a complete failure as a
parent.
Absolutely.
I would rather,
that's not fair to the kid.
I would marry a stripper and,
uh,
you know,
I would just,
I would just have fun with the stripper.
I would just do whatever I could,
you know,
fucker is,
she had one leg pointed west and one lake pointed east,
you know,
or north and south if she's standing up drinking coffee,
doing like one of those little ballet moves.
I just bag like that and then,
uh,
yeah.
Then they have a kid and be like,
listen,
this is the secret in life,
sweetheart.
Don't do anything that your mother did when she does become a stripper.
Is that like a reality show that they haven't come up with the daughters of
strippers?
Like what's her face?
I think a Kurt Cobain's daughter is going to be all right because their is such
a fuck up that it thinks I probably just jinxed her.
I probably just chased her.
All right.
Number three,
uh,
choose between attack by a bear or a lion on land in between.
Attacked by a shark or a crocodile in the water.
No fucking contest,
dude.
I would take a barren bear or a lion.
That's a quick death.
That's a quick one.
That bear comes up with dead bionic bitch slap.
That's it.
You fucking breaks your neck.
You have a sea lion kill something.
That's it.
It's over like an that's going after like major prey and it just crushes you.
Fucking wind pipe.
You're out in two seconds.
Did you ever yelled at footage of what's his face?
The Gay Lion Tamer out there.
The one who looked like,
uh,
what's his face from night at the Roxbury?
The AH,
Jesus Christ is fuck it.
Cold medicine.
What the fuck is the guy's name there?
Come on.
What was,
what's the name of that Guy Chris Catan.
That one.
The Gay Chris Catan.
Do you ever see when that fucking,
that lion grabbed that dude and it was over in two seconds.
It would,
he just went limp.
I take that in a second.
As opposed to a fucking shark.
You sitting out there,
shark comes up,
first thing it does is it bites and dia leg to see if your edible right just
takes a nice chunk out and Kinda,
you know,
like he's doing some sort of wine testing with your fucking thigh meat.
You know what else kills me is the fact you can't fucking see it.
You know,
your heads above the water and all the evil is just below it and you're sitting
there,
you know,
and I think that you hit still,
you got that cavemen DNA that would,
that would just be going off that there was something in the area despite the
fact that you couldn't see it,
you'd be trying to lift your fucking legs up.
I,
I think,
uh,
I think the real dilemma here is,
is between shark or a crocodile and,
uh,
I,
I would have to go,
I would have to go shark.
I just feel like they're,
it's a cleaner death.
You know,
they got those Ginsu knives,
teeth,
they just come in like a tiger shark.
It's just fucking over,
you know,
just a perfect fucking killing machine as they said and jaws.
But like a
alligators and crocodiles,
those fucking things.
Those are like those guys who aren't talent talented enough to be in the NFL,
the NHL.
So they just go out there and they tried to blow out guys knees,
you know,
alligators and crocodiles like the bill room and now skis of fucking predators.
You know,
just that thing when they grab on to you.
You know what I like about a shark?
It what?
You could just bite your leg off fucking alligator.
That they always seem to grab it and then they go into that role and they just
sold slowly twisted off.
You know,
like you're some cooked chicken and they're trying to take the leg.
This is getting fucking morbid.
That's what I would choose.
All right,
what else do we got here?
Uh,
have a beautiful lady who stinks,
smelly breath,
smelly ass pussy pits,
hair the works all sticking or an ugly fat bitch who smells great.
Uh,
I go with the ugly fat girls.
Smells great.
Absolutely because I could,
I could love her.
Where the other one who just smelled like shit but was beautiful.
It was probably carried herself like a beautiful lady would annoy me after a
while it I probably kill her,
you know,
why did you kill her?
Cause her fucking pussy stunk.
And she walked around like she was just self.
Am I being charged with that?
He think because if I am,
I want a lawyer.
Go Fuck yourself while Mr. Brewer,
you really just already incriminated yourself.
I don't care.
You know,
the prison will not smell as bad as her ass.
That was anything worse to fucking cold tea.
All right,
here we go.
Uh,
chimp,
first line backer built my friends and I frequently get in an argument over
whether a worlds,
a world's man competitor or NFL lineman could handle a chip and a fight.
I know chimps can rip faces off at our 10 times the strength of a normal man,
but a normal man is a tub of shit.
I bet a linebacker could rip some faces off to.
What do you think?
Uh,
yeah,
no contest.
The chimp would fuck the dude up.
Do Chimps don't fight.
I was going to happen.
I said fairly chips don't fight like people.
They're not gonna,
you know,
you've got to come out,
come out and touch gloves.
They're going to fuck it.
Sorry.
He's got a great jab watch out for it's right.
You know that fucking thing.
It's just going to jump on you.
I would tell you that time that monkey stole my hotel keys.
I was at Costa Rica.
Um,
the fuck was I doubt of Costa Rica way out in the bush.
You know,
army ants took over my fucking little Cabana and that type of shit.
So they had this pet monkey.
There of is a monkey.
I fucking hate monkeys.
I never had a problem with chimps,
but now that they'd rip people's faces off and then nuts and their feet off,
I have a problem with them.
Uh,
I like gorillas and I like orangutans.
Orangutans.
I was still,
it was tank t a g but it's wearing a tan.
I like those ones.
They seem like they've seen it all.
They've got that vibe.
They could just sit down and teach you about life.
But those little monkey motherfuckers,
I can't stand it.
Right.
So for some dumb reason,
cause I'm white,
I have to walk up to it.
A,
there's a fucking wild animal.
Let me put myself in danger and I walk up to this thing and a fucking jumps on
me.
Uh,
you know,
and it's one of those,
remember that,
that that video was shocked.
The monkey.
Okay.
Pop Up.
It was a little monkey that they was one of those monkeys.
The faces of death where they will fucking bag of that monkey's head till it
died.
That they ate his braids over that one.
Yeah.
It was one of those monkeys,
right?
This fucking thing jumped on me.
It wasn't half a second.
It turned itself upside down,
was hanging by its tail from my neck,
reached in my pockets,
grabbed my keys and ran back up a fucking tree.
This all happened like within like 1.8 seconds.
So my body reactions,
like what?
Wait,
what?
What?
Ah Fuck.
So if this thing actually wanted to fuck you up,
the things that going to come out fucking bobbing and weaving,
it's going to be running around the room,
jumping up off of shit.
You got to try to figure out where it is and it's just going to fucking land on
your face and that's going to be it.
It's going to tear your face off,
twist your foot off and rip your balls off and no linebacker stands a fucking
chance unless you know what,
what if they had on the equipment,
even though they tell you fingers off.
This is the amazing thing about how human beings survived,
is everything out there as far as I can tell,
is faster than us.
For the most part,
it is stronger that US faster and stronger,
but for the simple fact that we were smarter,
we were able to do all the horrific things that we've done with this nature.
You know,
with this nature,
with this planet,
you have to think about that shit.
Football players beat the fuck out of the nerds all through grade school and
high school.
Then what happens from the real deal goes down the end of the day.
Those nerds become bankers and those football players get enslaved and there you
sit in your house like a caged animal at the fucking zoo.
And where's that banker?
You don't even know what the fuck he looks like.
All those Facebook cunts that God damn Steve Jobs.
What are the most overrated human beings on the fucking planet?
They went in the end.
Follow up from October.
Where do eggs come from?
Yeah.
Where the eggs come out of.
Oh yeah.
I asked that.
I asked does it come out of their ass?
Did they have a little chicken pussy?
A little chicken,
Eh,
Vagina.
Billy boy.
Just listen to the podcast from October and you sort of asked where eggs come
out of a chicken.
He says,
I don't fuck chickens,
but,
well,
okay.
Yeah,
I do know where they come out of.
I know for a fact that the egg comes out of the hole that poop also comes out
of,
it's called the vent.
Bam educated.
You're welcome.
Oh,
that's disgusting.
Well,
no wonder that egg has a shell on it,
Huh?
So that's okay.
I can still eat eggs and not worry that I'm eating eggs shit.
Right.
Cause it's in that little,
uh,
that little more capsule.
It's called the vent.
Why doesn't a Fuckin a
yeah.
Oh,
a chicken have a pussy.
Is that because it's so small?
Is that what it is?
Is it,
I'd like,
you know,
when you get a car and there's,
you get the compact so there's not enough room for the radio.
So they turn it sideways like in the Chevy citation.
Is that what it is?
So they had to combine the ass hole and the birth canal l at the same time.
Yeah.
So every chicken takes it in the ass.
Is that what you're telling me?
Where does the rooster just nowhere to go.
I didn't get pregnant again.
It went up the shitter rather than up the vent.
Does a rooster have to bang a chicken at at a certain angle to make sure it goes
up the vent?
That doesn't make any fucking sense.
Is there a farmer out there that could show me a,
uh,
send me a diagram?
Yeah,
it's got a,
it's got a split at some point doesn't it?
They can't be some egg grown in your ass and you're also trying to take a
chicken dump.
You'd be constantly constipated,
you know?
And when,
when chickens lay eggs,
it's not like there's a bunch of shit all over it.
See Sir,
this is what it,
this is the great thing about life is you ask,
you answer a question and it just introduces all these others.
Now I realize,
you know,
it's like that little thing.
Like with each book I read,
I realized this is so much less than I know.
Okay.
See that.
So now I have a,
I have a hundred more questions and you know what?
You decided to reopen this Pandora's box.
Now w I need some
followup.
I got any farmers out there.
Huh?
Anybody else could tell me
it's got a split off like one of those t splits.
Like when you,
you know,
you and a friend listened to the same iPod.
Okay.
Eggs in one shit and the other.
That's like a game show.
It's time to play.
Put your hand and I'll put you a face under the chicken vent.
What do you think it's going to be?
Roll a dice isn't going to be an egg or is it
me?
Some chicken shit.
Um,
that's disgusting bill.
Well go fuck yourself.
I had to work with what I had there.
Um,
Hey,
speaking of failure,
I actually went on to youtube and I know these say everybody's seen these a
zillion times.
So you know what I love,
I love those compilation,
uh,
you know,
fail videos of 2010,
2011 and uh,
I was watching those laps night just laughing my ass off.
Just having a good time for you bill.
Is there any that you can remember that really a lot of face plants,
a lot of people taking it in the nuts and uh,
I'll tell you,
I can't believe what it takes to break your fucking neck because everybody was
like doing back flips and then like water skiing on their face,
like landing on their face and sliding three feet on the face and you're
thinking there's no way that guy's getting up.
And every time they get,
they get right back up.
This is something that I've noticed.
How bout the ladies is a lot of them because they spent their whole fucking
lives trying to attract a man who invariably is going to disappoint him because
he's a fucking idiot because he has a Dick,
right?
They spent so much time,
poof.
And their hair and Peyton up that God damn faces,
you know,
like some Kabuki cloud getting out of a God damn folks wagon that they,
a lot of them have the coordination of like a three year old,
you know,
I'm not talking about the athletic ones,
the ones that throw like dudes,
you know,
have little grunt in there.
You got a new girlfriend you didn't realize.
Yeah,
you,
he played high school softball.
That's cool.
It yells,
go outside and play catch,
right.
She's,
you see it.
She's already fucking amped up.
You know,
she gets out there,
he's got that look in her eye or fucking nipples are hard.
She's ready to go.
And you're out there going,
oh,
you know,
it's a lady.
Let's,
let's be easy.
So you tosser one,
you know,
borderline aren't underhanded trying to respect of the J J right?
She's got a vagina,
not too hard.
You Lob it over to her and then she throws it back and it gets a little grunting
there.
Pops you.
Mit makes your hands staying a little bit,
makes you a little bit nervous,
right?
The fuck am I with?
I'm not talking about women like that.
I'm talking about,
you know the,
Oh my God,
you guys,
that's so mean.
Lucas.
The Christmas lights.
Oh,
I love Christmas.
That girl,
those when they fall off fucking tables or whatever the fuck it.
Oh there they are going on rope swings.
Like when they fall,
they look like a fucking taught lean.
I like toddlers.
Don't realize they do.
They don't know enough to put the hands out to protect their face or they just
fall like a fucking sack of potatoes.
Those are my favorite videos because it's usually good looking women,
you know,
they're good looking so they know that all they gotta do is just do that Kabuki
thing.
If every day they just fucking wake up,
take one of those giant powder things and slam their face with it.
Paint their lips red like a goddamn bullseye that you know much toe.
A lot of people should grin most of their dreams.
They're going to come true or they got to come true.
You know what is [inaudible]?
The red lipstick,
everybody.
I used to think it was cause your lipstick,
you know sort of a red,
but it's a muted red.
You know it's an old school TV read as opposed to the high def HD.
Fucking a stick.
Your Dick in here read that.
The lipstick is,
you know,
I dunno,
I'm officially an old bastard.
You know it's this.
This is when you add in for all you youngsters out there.
This is when you,
you,
you got to know that your old,
first of all,
you're going to stutter uncontrollably for no apparent reason.
But beyond that,
this is how you're going to know your old is when you get to that age where you
can't tell if somebody is a hooker or if they work at the,
basically like a library or something hat got,
damn,
I should have a better example.
I can't tell the difference between a girl going out to the club or a girl
walking down the streets sucking Dick for 20 bucks a pop.
You know,
because I,
I've,
I've been old long enough that,
you know,
my idea of what a horror is,
the horrors of my generation already have kids who are like 18 1920 years of
age.
All right?
So now they're rebelling against their horror of a mother from the eighties
early nineties so they have to outdo what she did.
And in the process they dress like hookers dressed when I was coming of age.
I'm telling you when I'm out here and I'd drive down Hollywood boulevard where
all the club scene is,
you know,
gee bill,
why do you go that way?
There's all kinds of traffics cause I want to look at the ladies.
They're all out there.
I'll tell you what's in now.
Thick thighs.
Thank God about fucking time.
And I,
when I was a kid,
like a women,
they all had those skinny fucking legs,
you know those little Chihuahua legs,
you know,
and they have fucking mustard pumps from the 80s remember those girls now all of
a sudden it looks like this whole generation has been doing squats.
It's looking pretty good to me.
So anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Oh,
I was talking about why I was,
uh,
I mean I have no idea where that thought came from.
Kind of fucked at up on mustard pumps.
I can't back it up.
My brain doesn't go that way.
You know,
I just have to keep going forward,
which is why I'm sitting here with the podcast only going into my left ear and
not my right here,
but you know what?
And now,
like you feel bad for me,
but you know what,
I,
this has been a problem.
This has been a reoccurring fucking problem.
And all I do is wiggled the wires every week and be like,
okay,
now it's working,
you know,
knowing full fucking well that something bad's going to happen.
It's like ignoring the fact that,
you know,
the check engine light just came on.
[inaudible]
um,
money advice bill.
I'm an Otr truck driver.
What the fuck is that?
Off Track
vetting.
What does that o t I don't know what that is.
All right,
I'll take your word for it.
I'm an Otr truck driver and have a problem with blowing fucking money like a
politician.
I have a wonderful fiance with a great head on her shoulders and she is great
with money.
Uh,
every time I see the bank statements,
the balance is more and more so I know she's doing a bang up job with their
finances.
Well,
let me tell you something,
sir.
You are one perceptive son of a bitch.
He seen another beggar and I know that that must be a good thing.
Um,
so what's the fucking problem you say?
Well,
like I said,
I'm terrible with money,
so I got one of them.
I got one of them prepaid debit cards.
He literally wrote one of them.
I liked this guy,
talks like Elvis,
uh,
and every Tuesday payday,
my girl puts $50 on there so I can get groceries that way I don't turn into one
of these fat shits that ate every meal out out of the Wendy's,
out of the,
Ah,
God,
this guy is great.
He's man or Dan loaded up and trucking.
We going to do what they say can't be done.
We're gonna get some hookers at the next drug stuff.
We ain't can wear condoms and shoots some drugs and we'll all get fuckin aids
and pass it all around.
Um,
well,
$50 is good for one week of groceries,
but it's like pulling fucking teeth for extra money like say for drinks or some
rubbers?
No,
like for drinks or some extra curriculars.
Am I an asshole for thinking I deserve a few extra bucks or what the fuck bill,
by the way,
Nia has a sexy fucking voice and go fuck yourself.
Um,
okay.
Are you an asshole for thinking you deserve a few extra bucks?
Absolutely.
The fact that that poor woman is legally bound to you and you,
you have no concept of how to hold on to money,
that would be like,
I mean,
you're a guy like you're supposed to fucking earn a living to support a family.
Right?
Okay.
If you have no concept of that,
that would be like if she had no concept of,
of like how to have a baby or how to blow somebody's,
you know what I mean?
Okay.
Cause that's what their job is sucking Dick and make it
idiot.
Oh God.
Measured by head of the balls to run for president after doing this podcast for
five years.
How I,
how easy would it be to take me down?
MMM.
Do.
Why don't you learn about money?
Did you really just want to float around?
Like with your fucking eyes wide open,
just not getting it.
Don't you want to understand money.
She's given you 50 bucks a week.
You know why cause you to fucking stupid.
He gets 60
okay,
and I'm sure you can crawl under a truck and modify it.
I'm not saying you straight across the board dumb,
but to not,
not to understand money.
It's,
I swear to God,
dude is one of the dumbest things you honestly,
and this is for everybody,
it's one of the dumbest things you could ever do in life is I understand not
understanding money up to about 1819 but once you're to the point where you can
go to a library,
we can go on the Internet and you can just just read up on it,
okay?
If you don't understand money,
you're going to be behind the eight ball for your entire fucking life and you're
basically going to be an indentured servant to credit card companies and banks
and your life is going to suck way more than it needs to.
Okay?
I'm not saying that just because you understand money.
One are your kidneys isn't going to shit the bed.
Bad Shit's already going to happen.
You don't need to compound it with not understanding money.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
This woman is the best thing that ever fucking happen to you.
You don't understand money and you want monitored for drinks and some extra
curriculars.
What does that mean?
An eight ball.
Okay.
If you start with drinks and then you say,
I like how safe for drinks or some extra curriculars like boozing to you isn't
even an extracurricular activity.
That's just,
you know,
okay,
let's like nourishment for you.
So I'm,
I'm assuming that extra curriculars is at least a bag of weed or maybe some
condoms to bag some trucker whore.
Truckstop whore,
you know?
Listen sir,
you got a great fucking woman,
but she's only gonna put up with you not understanding money for so long because
at some date points she's going to want a god damn man.
Okay.
Especially once you have a couple of kids,
she doesn't need you being some adult kids.
So I would say read up on money and you'd understand what a favor she's doing
for you.
If you,
if your bank balance is going up,
you're doing better than 90% of the people out there.
All right?
So here's a good thing.
You got to fucking angel and she's smart and just read up on money.
All right?
She's also keeping in shape.
Go buy groceries.
Don't become a tub of shit.
Yeah.
You know,
she's basically without you even realizing,
or possibly even her,
she's laying down the gauntlet here.
She's basically saying in her own cute way.
I don't want to be married to some fat broke trucker.
All right?
So read up on money.
Keep eating your fucking pears and fruit out there and a,
and you'll be fine.
Alrighty.
With
their eyes.
[inaudible].